non mémoire des angles ce soir je reçois
harry roselmack je le reçois pour son
premier roman ne vit lui qu'il signe
d'un pseudonyme agi bungo c'est votre
maman enfin voila c'est le nombre de
jeunes filles de venir voter pendant que
nos deux jeunes fils le fait que ce soit
le monde ma mère c'est effectivement
très important parce que ça explique
pourquoi j'ai voulu donc prendre ce
pseudonyme pour pas que roselmack ce nom
très captée par la télévision soit aussi
le motif peut-être d'intérêt pour ce
livre mais bongo c'est aussi mon
identité parce que j'ai une partie de ma
famille qui s'appelle bongo donc c'est
c'est le signe que j'assume complètement
ce livre et que c'était pas le
l'objectif pour moi n'était pas de me
cacher ou de me dissimuler derrière ce
pseudonyme d'accord donc et nos vies du
donc c'est nos vies lui est alors
derrière on a un quatrième de couverture
qui est extrêmement intéressant parce
que je vois les mots ils sont des
seconds des phrases des minutes
un thriller saisissant et singulier sur
l'être le savoir la liberté le pouvoir
local
une ambition derrière ce mur et je
trouve que c'est gonflé quand je dis
gonfler ses qu'harry roselmack aurait pu
faire un petit 10 tranquille en vendre
plein et on lui aurait pas posé de
problème au contraire vous êtes
compliquer la tâche pourquoi j'aurais
effectivement très bien pu écrire un
essai sur la diversité dans les médias
et le signe harry roselmack l'an mil
minimum à peu près là mais non j'avais
vraiment pas envie de faire ça c'est à
dire que ce que j'ai recherché en
écrivant ce livre c'est une liberté dans
l'écriture c'est à dire que j'aime
écrire mais l'écriture journalistique
est une écriture très contrainte son
objet de respecter les faits c'est celle
ci s'est même du journalisme là j'avais
envie de d'élargir ce cadre maximum mais
ma grande surprise était de compte est
de constater que cette liberté était
loin d'être totale est loin d'être aussi
aux grandes que ce à quoi je pouvais
m'attendre départ me suis rendu compte
que lorsque vous créez un personnage que
vous lui donner une identité tôt et ont
voulu donner une cohérence à un
caractère un environnement et bien il
réagit en fonction de ces paramètres là
et que vous décidez plus finalement de
la façon dont il va réagir face à ces à
ces épreuves là et ça ça a été vraiment
une révélation
en fait on voit des personnages qui font
tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour plaire à
leurs créateurs
parce que il ya quand en plaisant à
l'écrivain qu'on va pouvoir exister si
on lui plaît il va nous donner à vivre
de l'action est-ce que c'est notre
boulot à nous sur terre de plaire à
notre créateur c'est une bonne question
le fait est que ya l'un des deux
personnages qui effectivement a fait le
constat de son impuissance face à la
volonté de l'auteur est ici donc s'y
conforme et espère ainsi aller au bout
et sortir finalement de ce qu'ils
considèrent comme un enfer mais il ya
l'autre personnage qui lui se rebelle
contre cette volonté d'auteur qui pour
lui et pour sa famille et destructrice
et ses deux parcours à son deux parcours
très différents et je pense
qu'effectivement on est dans une société
où certaines personnes considèrent qu'il
faut effectivement se conformer à un
certain nombre un certain nombre de
règles qui seraient des règles imposées
par l'au delà et d'autres personnes qui
au contraire estiment qu'il doit vivre
leur vie et ne pas les faire fi un peu
de voilà de ses dogmes qu'on pourrait
vouloir leur imposer donc je pense qu'on
a les deux situations dans la vie puis
jean bol il est à vous un recul football
moi j'ai envie de lui mettre une claque
est pas un coup de poing parce que le le
coup de poing et plus je l'en mais la
claque est plus vexatoire donc voilà je
viens vous avez envie d'être vexatoires
donc une chine ball l'occasion de
pousser un coup de gueule contre quoi
contre la
la disposition de la loi de maîtrise de
l'immigration qui qui porte sur le test
adn
au plan des d'un regroupement familial
alors moi je reviendrai pas sur la
polémique qui offre un niveau de détail
pour nationale je pense que là
effectivement c'est c'est
allez un peu trop loin dans la polémique
et chercher la petite bête là où il n'y
a pas lieu d'en avoir mais cette
disposition sur l'adn elle est
l'illustration parfaite d'une évolution
certains diraient d'une dérive de la
politique qui aujourd'hui n'est plus un
système de confrontations de la pensée
un système d'idéologie mais de plus en
plus et ça ça touche la droite comme la
gauche
un logiciel de 2,2 qui hélas ont grosso
modo pour trouver des solutions très
concrètes aux problèmes des français ça
ça porte un nom et ce nom c'est le
pragmatisme
alors ce pragmatisme moi je considère
qu'il ne faut pas il ne faut pas le
jeter aux orties et c'est à dire que les
français aujourd'hui ils veulent des
réponses concrètes ils veulent pas donc
de bois idéologique thématique de
principe en dans la mare des principes
on veut des choses concrètes
sauf que là je pense que le politique
doit garder quand même une certaine
hauteur et lorsqu'il s'agit de la pensée
pas forcément idéologique mais de la
pensée humaniste
je pense que cette pensée humaniste doit
rester présent dans la réflexion du
politique et dans ses décisions
or là on a on est dans l'illustration
parfaite d'une décision prise pour
régler un problème précis concrets de
façon très pragmatique mais en ignorant
complètement les principes humanistes de
la république française qu'est ce que
vous avez signé la pétition contre
test adn non je n'ai pas signé cette
pétition je me dois en tant qu' en tant
que journaliste et ça c'est un devoir de
réserve et voilà j'ai juste que je
respecte vraiment je ne peux pas prendre
une position officielle contre un texte
du gouvernement je n'ai pas envie
voilà d'être étiqueté est ce que cette
proposition est raciste
cette proposition n'est pas raciste
force est de reconnaître qu'elle est
discriminatoire je fais une différence
entre les deux on ne peut pas
effectivement considérer qu'il y à un
modèle pour la famille ni française donc
un droit de la famille française est un
modèle pour les familles étrangères il
ya un droit français de la famille et ce
droit français de la famille s'applique
aux familles françaises comme aux
familles étrangères alors sifflé c'est
l'occasion pour nous de revenir sur des
arts temps ça proteste un peu derrière
ça proteste un peu parce que ça fait
piquer to basics où tu peux
donc ce coup de sifflet nous donne
l'occasion de revenir sur une critique
qui nous a pas été très favorable et là
j'en ai une
à propos justement de nos vies nous
c'est eric naulleau dans l'émission de
ruquier qui a parlé de votre texte je ne
comprends pas pourquoi vous mettez en
danger comme ça avec un livre qui n'est
pas suffisamment travaillé on vous vous
essayer à l'érotisme et là ça ne marche
pas ou vous risquez à la comparaison
avec des auteurs confirmés comme philip
k dick qui a fait ça en beaucoup mieux
il ya beaucoup de phrases qui ne sont
pas possibles qui n'aurait jamais dû
être dans votre livre tellement elles
sont maladroites pour moi c'est un livre
d'amateurs alors comment on réagit
qu'est ce que vous avez fait à deuxième
de hanches genoux rangés
j'ai essayé de prendre tout ça avec le
maximum de détachement même de faire un
peu d'humour envoyée mais non mais ce
qui est décevant c'est que j'ai quand
même vraiment le sentiment concernant ce
monsieur que sa critique est tu est une
est une posture c'est à dire que son
rôle c'est de critiquer déjà donc ça
pose un problème
il ya certaines des critiques qu'il
formule qui montre que soit il a mal du
livre ou que il a mal compris
l'intention de l'auteur lorsqu'il parle
d'érotisme
dans ce climat que hadji bongo c'est
serré à l'érotisme qui le fait mal c'est
une erreur il n'y a pas une once
d'érotisme devance lyon sauf si eric
naulleau ne ne connaît pas la définition
d'érotisme
il ya des scènes rieussec ce volume qui
sont des scènes de pure contexte qui
permet de décrire un état d'esprit des
personnages mais il ya aucun moment je
me suis dit je vais essayer de le
titiller un petit peu le
lecteur dans ce sens là j'ai jamais
essayé de faire d'érotisme bon est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment des fois
qu'on vous faire la peau
si je puis dire non mais en l'occurrence
il est parti du principe qu'un
journaliste ne sait pas écrire de la
fiction donc partant de ce principe là
il a déroulé le fil et il a démonté
systématiquement et de façon
caricaturale le bouquin et c'est comme
un peu s'il ya des écrivains se
mettaient à animer des émissions
voilà c'est ce qu'il m'a dit d'ailleurs
si vous imaginez vous que tous les
écrivains venus présenter le 20h soit
quoi je dis pourquoi pas et je suis sûr
qu'il y en a qui sont capables de très
bien le faire là où la raison c'est
lorsqu'il me compare à des auteurs comme
philip k.dick comme d'autres évidemment
qu'un premier enfant et on peut pas le
lire
en comparant aux maîtres du genre et en
disant c'est moins bien évidemment ce
sera moins bien on peut pas lire un
livre en cherchant derrière chaque ligne
à la faute en voulant trouver l'argument
qui va faire mouche à l'antenne parce
que ça va être un argument vexatoires
comme la petite claque
si on lit un livre cet état d'esprit là
on rentre pas dedans et évidemment on va
voilà on va pas se laisser emporter par
l'histoire et ça risque effectivement
d'être décevant au final ce miroir pour
figurer une
vos admiration aux alma car qu'est-ce
que vous avez choisi vous êtes venu avec
un avec quelqu'un avait quelque chose
dans votre poche car tu m'avais que
l'une des plus belles choses du monde à
mon sens un livre déjà
et voilà l'inde est l'un de mes auteurs
préférés qui te prendre pour lui montrer
hubert selby junior ah oui d'accord
las exit to brooklyn effectivement ça
c'est du bon du monde
c'est le premier que je suis d'ailleurs
voilà c'est un instinct auteurs nord
américain qui a grandi et vécu à
brooklyn d'ailleurs et c'est de là qu'il
a tiré son inspiration pour son pour son
premier succès qui est qui et se livrant
à la cette exit to brooklyn qui a été
adapté et il veut adapter au cinéma tout
à fait tout comme le second qui a donné
ce film aurait pu même pour un film que
beaucoup de gens ont vu ce que je trouve
admirable chez cet auteur c'est ça sa
capacité à décrire les les états d'âme
et la psychologie de ses personnages
c'est à dire que ce qui est ce qui est
incroyable chez cet auteur c'est que le
beau absolue côtoie le
l'horreur absolue et ses personnages
sont souvent sur le fil son entre les
deux et vous ne savez jamais s'ils vont
basculer d'un côté ou de l'autre et ça
je trouve ça extraordinaire c'est à dire
que il a un recueil de nouvelles qui
s'appelle chansons de la neige
silencieuse dans lequel vous avez voilà
des petites histoires de la vie parfois
très quotidienne et notamment une
histoire où un monsieur est avec sa
fille et vous vous demandez à chaque
ligne
à chaque page si ce monsieur va
commettre une erreur parce que sa fille
sa fille il énerve un peu pour tout un
tas de petites choses mais il ya une
tension dans l'écriture est une façon de
voir de décrire si les cas hier les
actions de ces personnages vous a
l'impression que ces personnages sont
capables de tout et ça c'est vraiment
extraordinaire
[Musique]
harry roselmack je vois avec une petite
caméra c'est donc que nous sommes dans
notre séquence vidéo intime à l'occasion
pour vous de nous emmener dans un moment
d'intimité
qu'est-ce que vous avez choisi comme
moment d'intimité c'est quelque chose de
bon je n'ai pas souvenir extrêmement
précis mais c'est quelque chose qui m'a
marqué gt gt très petit je devais avoir
trois quatre ans nous allons rentrer
dans un magasin et j'ai vu mon père qui
est quelqu'un de très calme très pondéré
de très mesurée de très respectueux j'ai
vu mon père avoir des mots avec un
monsieur et j'ai compris je ne sais pas
si j'ai entendu quelque chose de si
c'est mon père revenant vers nous qui
nous a dit le fait est qu'on ait pas
rentrer dans ce magasin on erreur encore
de voiture et on est parti mais j'ai
compris qu'ils avaient eu une dispute
parce que ce monsieur n'est elle pas les
noirs
et c'est la première fois dans ma vie et
ça m'est pas arrivé souvent après
d'ailleurs que vous les avez jamais été
vraiment victimes dans le nord mais
c'est là c'est la première fois que j'ai
compris qu'il y avait une différence
entre noirs et blancs et que j'ai
compris il ya des gens qui n'aimaient
pas ce que j'ai fait c'est les
circonstances restent assez diffuse
comme ça mais ce sentiment de me dire
mais pourquoi ce monsieur veut pas
comprendre en magasin il ne veut pas
prendre parce qu'on est noir mais
pourquoi comprenant tout d'un coup que
voilà ma couleur de peau constitué
différence que certains ne va pas passer
au delà de cette différence et nous
pouvons nous accepter ne serait ce que
dans un magasin où on allait pourtant
acheté dépenser de l'argent acheter des
choses est ce que vous êtes imaginer
projeté le jour votre fille pourra
peut-être avoir ce sentiment
et comment vous vous allez réagir
écoutez je me suis pas projeté pour une
raison simple c'est à dire que je je
ferai tout je fais tout et je pense que
l'une ou l'un des aspects l'une des
facettes de
de mon exposition aujourd'hui c'est que
justement elle n'est pas à faire agents
de comportement je pense que plus on
sera présent voilà dans la sphère
publique sous différentes formes
sportives intellectuelles médiatiques
etc
mais je pense que voilà on aura moins à
faire je l'espère à ce genre de réaction
voilà c'était donc les mémoires des
zincs de hachage ebunga dit harry
roselmack
c'était pour nos vies lui c'est aux
éditions de courcelles et je vous le
conseille pour ça en savoir un peu plus
sur harry roselmack
merci
[Musique]